president Trump is starting a new effort
to get rid of Obamacare the Republican
Party will soon be known as the party of
health care why meanwhile the White
House still has not seen special counsel
Robert Muller's report that hit that the
Presidents Attorney General says clears
the president of collusion with Russia
Attorney General William bars says he
will release more details in the weeks
ahead Paula Reid is at the White House
Paula good morning good morning as
Washington awaits those additional
details from the Muller report president
Trump and his Democratic rivals agree on
one thing they'd rather talk about
health care and in a closed-door meeting
yesterday with lawmakers President Trump
called for lower health care costs
according to lawmakers who were in the
room and in a legal filing earlier this
week the Trump Justice Department made
an unusual announcement that it now
supports a full repeal of Obamacare but
the White House has offered no details
on a replacement plan a Democrat seized
the opportunity to focus on health care
as a Republican efforts to repeal
Obamacare
help them retake the house in November
yesterday they introduced new
legislation to expand enrollment for the
Affordable Health Care Act to millions
more people Obamacare ensures more than
eleven million Americans including
offering protections for 52 million
people with pre-existing conditions a
recent poll found that 50% of Americans
view the law favorably but it'll likely
take over a year for all the legal
issues surrounding Obamacare to resolve
keeping the issue front and center
through 2020 bianna Paula thank you it's
so interesting because you have as
Attorney General and as HHS secretary
disagreeing with the Justice
Department's decision for a full repeal
I've been there a lot of congressional
fight yeah and congressional Republicans
don't seem that easy with it either
many Democrats view it as a gift we
shall see